[Music]
how many of you looked at your finances
this morning I look at my finances every
day every morning I look at my finance I
want to confront management of the
household I am in charge of the money in
my household every single day for 35
years I don't want money I want my money
having babies this little dude on this
50 what's his name whatever I need him
to make some babies for me okay I need
him to populate my other bank accounts
so the reason I look at how much money I
have every day is I got I gotta put him
to work this dude needs to get to work
even though he's dead he needs to go to
work for me money is trash money is
garbage okay help me out here cash is
king that's what you were told you know
who told you that the banks told you
that cash flow is King cash flow say it
again man
cash flow is King need motivation watch
the top 10 with believe Nation hey it's
Evan Carmichael and I make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that Push by being surrounded by the
best so today let's learn from one of
the best Grant Cardone and my take on
his top 50 rules for success
enjoy
rule number two have multiple products
to offer so if you give someone a call
to give someone a stack of like 200
leads to dial through right and you get
a Salesman who wants to
speak to everybody like is it the same
no money they have no job and they want
to sell a ten thousand dollar product
and they waste 45 minutes in that call
would that be smart or not smart he
shouldn't have started that call with
one product
why why because he works at a company
that has one product that's stupid go
some other places
okay who does that Amazon doesn't do it
grocery stores don't do it uh Starbucks
doesn't do it no but nobody no matter
how good that one product is nobody can
build a business or any kind of success
on one product or let's say a couple of
products two or three products right the
average company out there yeah you need
more than one product you need more
product okay like if I try to hit
everybody with a ten thousand dollar
product or even a one dollar even one
even a hundred somebody with a one
dollar product I missed the guy that
wants to spend ten thousand so the idec
value okay so the idea is go work for a
company that has a whole Suite of
products gives you a much you can sell
something to everybody right basically
right yeah okay I like that cool like we
probably have I don't know we probably
have a hundred different products on our
website rule number three never quit on
Financial Freedom this used to be a goal
of mine to make one million dollars a
year
that was my goal when I was 35 years old
one day I said to myself one day I said
self little g dog
little g dog one day young man I wrote
this over and over and over again I
talked to myself in the mirror I'd sit
on the toilet and say one day one day
I'm gonna I'm gonna make a million
dollars one day one day and people used
to tell me that's crazy dude
like why do you think so big this is
when people were telling me not to
they're like why do you need to do all
that why do you just be happy just be a
good person okay be happy that you live
in America be happy that you have meals
and be happy you got good health and all
the things that the people around you
that quit on money that quit on
Financial Freedom that quit on
possibility that quit on their potential
all the things those people will tell
you
to try to convince you
to quit
when in reality what they're really
trying to do is make sense of why they
quit rule number four be the most
Dependable person I would tell my 25
year old self dude do whatever you have
to do
to make sure you don't ruin your name
you have to be the most Dependable
person anybody knows
starting with yourself you have to be
the person you depend on okay so if
smoking weed on the weekends or drinking
or having hangovers or hanging out with
those people like makes you feel less
about yourself the less you have less
trust for yourself you've got to knock
those things off when this is done maybe
make a list
no no make a list go maybe make a list
of things that you need to knock off to
destroy your own personal sense of trust
in yourself this is a big thing that I
did when I was 25. I started doing
whatever I told somebody I would do I
was gonna do if I told you I was going
to punch you in the mouth I punch you in
the mouth right then okay if I told you
I was going to be there at four o'clock
I'd be there early if I told you I was
going to stay late I would stay late
whatever it was I started building trust
back within myself because the reality
is nobody is going to trust me
I had destroyed so much trust and
respect with others
and told them over and over again oh
it's gonna be different this time so old
25 year old Grant rebuild the trust you
have in yourself
and keep doing that until other people
start saying hey you changed you're
different now and that hurts that
started happening literally within about
three to six months of me starting to
make that commitment to say hey I'm
going to start rebuilding my own
personal trust in myself my personal
self-esteem came up I wasn't using drugs
anymore I wasn't using alcohol anymore I
wasn't going out on the weekends I was
working when my friends were playing
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five start taking
risks so
I'm just gonna look it up just so I
don't I'm entrepreneur yeah okay you
know what you ever looked it up I kind
of know what intuitively someone who
starts businesses and you know person
who organizes and operates a business or
business is taking on listen but this is
the important part this is good for your
young viewer taking on greater than
normal Financial Risk in order to do so
by definition the second half of that
most people are not entrepreneurs
because they never take on any risk like
they're they're holding on to their
money they got cash in the banks they
got equity in their houses they're
saving money saving for retirement if
you're doing any of that versus putting
the balls against the wall right you're
like what are you doing dude you're
you're more committed me people are more
committed to the equity in their home
than they are to the equity of their
brand or business so I made this mistake
for years in your own life yeah yeah you
must operate
okay you must operate like
your life depends on it
okay life-threatening life-threatened I
operate best when I am under a threat
time threat Financial threat uh threat
to lose something there's got to be a
loss for you to stay on your game this
is why I tell so many people get your
money out of the bank and get it back
into the marketplace do not have cash
sitting in the Bank cash in the bank is
exactly what your mom and daddy told you
it was it is an emergency a security
blanket and why Johnny has money in in
the wall of his house is because he
first had this idea I'm gonna put money
there to avoid the IR and the S and
number two I'm going to have it there
just in case I need it I'll go get me a
little two inches of whatever I need of
it okay Johnny's got to get that money
out of the wall out of the bank
okay and back into the system so it pays
him rule number six stop making excuses
I did not come for money I came from
nothing
nothing I there was a time when I could
not afford this jacket
that I have on so if you're struggling
with money today I understand
I also understand that if you come from
nothing that should not be a reason you
stay with nothing
once you drop the reasons and the
excuses and the problems and the economy
and the government and we just changed
over
then you'll just change over
once you draw I'm too young I'm too old
once you drop the excuses and decide hey
I want success I want to be happy who
wants to be happy
good everybody wants to be happy who
wants to be healthy excellent who wants
a lot of friends
excellent rule number seven don't waste
your money don't spend money on dumb
stuff
25 years old keep this in mind for 35
years I didn't spend one penny on
alcohol not one penny on drugs literally
what I was saving
about I wasn't I wasn't doing dumb stuff
on the weekends I wasn't wrecking cars
and getting in trouble I wasn't having
to hire lawyers I didn't waste any money
for 25 years on dumb stuff you know when
you don't drink you don't gamble people
to drink Gamble they take risks they
would never ever take
right they don't show up when they
needed to the next day when they do show
up they show up with a hangover none of
that happened to me for 25 years forget
making money forget adding skills forget
getting talented the fact that I was no
longer destroying myself my self-worth
my respect I wasn't making mistakes
wasn't getting in car wrecks wasn't
having to hire lawyers wouldn't wouldn't
happen to be thrown in jail none of that
was happening for 25 years if you can
just stay out of trouble
be a wild man but stay out of trouble if
you could just do that I guarantee you
that'll be successful okay and keep in
mind I wasn't wasting money that means
I'm not wasting money on drugs and
alcohol and bad decisions and bad people
and uh the VIP bottles and trips last
minute oh let's go to Vegas this weekend
we can't afford it but let's do it
to be life is to be lived you only have
one life that's what my friends were
saying to me they were sucking me down
the vortex of Destruction
so imagine if you spent the next five or
ten years not wasting money on
this is the hard part now this is number
four watches cars trips and [ __ ]
I wasn't spending money on any of that
stuff
my friends were going on trips to Greece
for three days I said dude I I don't I
haven't earned that trip yet okay I'm
not going to Greece for three days
because I haven't earned the right to go
to Greece for three days
now I just finish I'm on my fourth week
Rome Bucharest I'm just telling you the
upstate if you paid the price today and
don't do the [ __ ] little brand I'm
not talking to you I'm talking to little
Grant
okay if you don't do the dumb [ __ ] right
now I went to Rome Bucharest Dubai let's
see if I missed one Singapore Malaysia
Thailand the Maldives and now
Mykonos okay one day I'm gonna go spend
a month or two on that yacht right there
I guarantee you I must spend a month or
two on that yeah it's all going to be
paid out of passive income passive
income cash flow okay I made a decision
at 25 not to spend any money out of
earned money see this is what the super
success will do they go all in okay so
in 25 years old I made a decision until
I have extra money so much extra money
that I don't have to worry about living
I don't have to worry about food I don't
have to worry about bills I don't have
to worry about emergencies
I'm not going to invest any of that
money and when I do invest it it's going
to go into something that will produce
more cash flow for me for 25 years this
is what people don't know about
you guys hear me ranting having fun
throwing my stuff on the internet what
you don't know what you didn't see was
the 25 years of me just stacking cash
waiting
to find the right vehicle to invest that
money in rule number eight set big
enough goals for yourself see this is
the problem is a young salesman dude I
was like okay I'm gonna make 80 grand a
year it isn't worth it
like like like if I make 80 grand a year
as a Salesman
I'm making seven thousand dollars a
month and I live in Miami you're not
going to do it changes nothing the
opportunity has to change your life
significantly enough that you're willing
to read study dive in right you add a
zero to that right there you had a zero
to that 80. now I'm willing to learn
every human being is like this by the
way every human being on this planet
Maybe I'm Wrong tell me if I'm wrong
comment please I add a zero to that
you're going to do stuff that you
wouldn't have done just a moment before
ago okay if I can show you how to how to
go from eighty thousand to eight hundred
thousand all of a sudden your creativity
you like I think I just met Van Gogh
God damn I got some Madonna coming out
of my butt
okay
whoa whoa whoa I got music in my head
like like ding ding ding ding you like
you because why man because
yeah maybe the glass underneath my feet
don't hurt so bad
right because why because the Gold's big
enough most people do not have goals
that will change their lives therefore
they cannot lean into the opportunity
hard enough for those of you who own
businesses you need to create rings in
your business
okay so that Natalie can see hey man I
can go outside this these I can go
outside these rings and there's more
opportunity out here for Financial
Freedom or she stays right here and she
doesn't resent me she resents her
because I keep throwing them out of here
I'm like hey there's a twenty thousand
dollar product you can sell right here
there's a five thousand dollar product
you can get benefit from here oh by the
way there's a million dollars out here
if you want to rule number nine man up
and do it big you said that so you
weren't successful early on when was the
shift what was it like that moment where
all of a sudden when I was 51 51 yeah
61. you're older than that yeah you
don't like that yeah yeah tell me what
was the shift what was it 2010 man tell
me 2010 I was just like I had I had a
little bit of success you know I had
three companies that were doing well
right and and what what those companies
there was a sales training a speaking
business okay
that I had been doing for 20 years
and uh they had really become just about
me collecting a fee
we would Market it we we owned the the
production of the the event the only
difference was I wasn't getting a
speaking fee I was getting a piece of
the gate okay so I didn't actually do
any speaking for speaking about sales it
was all sales and it was industry
specifically yeah it was Automotive I
was very very dependent upon the
automobile industry so so I realized
number one I'll never be defended upon
one industry again ever
uh number two uh the other business was
a Consulting business it was similar and
yeah that that I didn't run I was a
partnership and I collected a royalty
but and that was great for years it was
great until it wasn't right right and
then the third business was I would take
all the money from the first two import
into real estate because I knew that
real estate would live longer than I
could right and it would work better
than I could so the problem with all
three of those though is I never did it
big
like I never did it big big so I had
guys that had worse ideas and worse
products that were beating me in the
marketplace
I'm like that his stuff sucks dude and
but he beat me right because he's
advertising like a madman and poor money
addict exactly he he was like like and I
was making fun of him but the truth is
he was Manning up in the game and I
wouldn't uh there's a guy named uh well
there's a number of them I mean there's
a bunch of companies there was a bunch
of guys around me an advertising
marketing another sales training company
they were pouring money on the deal and
I wasn't I was saving money right rule
number 10 think in terms of 10x you must
think in terms of 10x
you have to think about expansion
exponential moves so whether it's ten
thousand you have 100
000 you have I'm just talking about
money for a second or whether it's a 10
million dollars okay maybe it's a
charity that you raised last year you
raised a hundred thousand for
Make-A-Wish okay and you're like what
are we gonna do this year we got to be
we got to beat last year we got to beat
it yeah but why don't you not beat it
why don't you stomp it in the ground and
act like it was dumb
that's exactly what I've done with my
businesses for the last seven or eight
years the first 20 years I thought small
I acted small I tried to preserve my
position okay number one you have to
give up your position you must give up
your position
number two the second thing I've done
over the last seven or eight years is
exponentially just grown grown all my
Brands my name my recognition uh the
businesses the top line I have been
willing to put money at risk to 10x my
business rule number 11 invest in
yourself first you should have no money
my financial advice to any young kid is
like dude invest all the money in
yourself first
every penny and yourself and you're
educating yourself education brand
clothes looking good uh teeth whatever
whatever whatever you need to make
yourself feel good about yourself right
and and then invest in yourself in your
friends in in your neighborhood like
like so you feel good when you walk up
if you need to go to rehab go to rehab
pay the 30 grand
go there clean up you know if you've
made a bunch of mistakes with people go
pay go go clean all that [ __ ] so you
don't have your attention on it and then
whatever invest in yourself and then
sooner or later if you're doing
investing the right things you're going
to do better rule number 12 look for
opportunities I can't build something
big and not need people I have to have
people I become more and more dependent
upon great people loyal people uh
competent people as I get bigger so
that's what you're really looking for
opportunity will it change my life when
you go work for a company when you guys
make a a a a a career change go work for
somebody that has opportunity that can
change lives don't don't go where you're
good at a job it doesn't matter if
you're good at a job go where there's a
vehicle that can take you on a journey
you guys leave this environment right
now you're going to go to some job
you're not going to get this every day
you're not going to hear this every day
you're not going to get the stimulation
they're like what am I doing but we all
need this every day I need it every day
man I gotta every day I gotta be like
what's the opportunity man I got to wake
up every day what's the opportunity man
huh I got two picks up in my eyelids I'm
like
what is it
what's the opportunity man huh what is
the opportunity what is the opportunity
where is the opportunity and it looks
good
you look good dude
foreign
and dude I want to be able to have so
much opportunity to do so much crazy
stuff that I can act like an idiot rule
number 13 you need a get rich plan I
made a commitment when I was a 25 years
old and broke okay I came up with a new
plan first thing I did was this okay
I made a plan so I could
retire rich
actually with me you could just drop the
retire thing because once you start
making money you're like I don't want to
retire I just want to make money man
okay no but most people don't like money
because they never have enough man to
have any fun with it
right or or they make a little bit of
money and they blow it and then the next
thing you know they're out of work and
they're like oh I hate money because the
last time I had money I blew it all I
went to strip joints I bought a Ferrari
erected I got in trouble next you see
what I'm saying Michael Tyson probably
doesn't really like money because every
time he got it he screwed it up
but but for those of you you need to get
rich plant
you need to get rich plan you don't need
to get by a plan right now you got to
get my plan I want the get rich plan so
you need to understand what that takes
and the first thing it takes on the get
rich plan is income you got to increase
your income if you make if you make if
you got a job making 36 Grand a year you
got to wake up and say you will never
ever ever ever have anything if you keep
that job at 36 Grand a Year by the way
the job is not the problem it's the 36
that is the problem okay
so you got to figure out dude how do I
get from 36 to 360.
oh my God that's going to be hard not
really if you take a look first of all
look at your commitment okay man I'm a
waitress okay good there's other
waitresses that if they're making 360
Grand a year you have to first make the
decision I know this sounds esoteric
nothing happens without
the decision
to get rich and understand the plan you
have doesn't work
okay because the plan your mom and dad
had was never a decision to get rich it
was to get by
right that's why they said diversify
that's why they said buy a house
remember the house that was one of the
plans a house does not make you rich
it's impossible it ties you down there's
no income associated with it okay so
every decision's got to be this I got to
get this number up to that that's why I
don't buy a house because me buying a
house doesn't get me 360 a year you get
it or 3 million a year right what gets
me that is income rule number 14 build
up a team there's a way to make a cold
Market warm right you need a team you
guys all of you need a team you're going
to start with Primerica that you know
the entry is cheap it doesn't cost a lot
to get involved but you need a team
and and what happens is you can only
knock on so many so many doors you can
only make so many phone calls so this is
a mistake that I made when I was uh 25
years old I I wanted to keep all the
money for myself well there was no money
right I was making everybody needs to
understand Grant has not always been
this guy flying in a jet
okay I was making sixty thousand dollars
a year
and trying to figure out how to make
another 10.
okay okay now I'll make 70. nothing
changed
your life doesn't change you got 10
grand left over what do you do with it
typically people spend it
that didn't change anything so I
wouldn't hire anybody I didn't have an
assistant I didn't have anybody doing
the stuff I didn't know how to do nobody
was loading up the CRM nobody was
calling my customers I was one little
sales guy I looked around me and there
was a bunch of other sales guys and none
of them had assistance so I kept doing
what these uh uh uh igmoranus people
were doing
and then I looked at businesses What do
businesses do
oh they got assistance they got help
they got support they got phone lines
they got a business they got an office
right so I'm like I got to get a company
I didn't need to go start my own
business I needed an assistant okay I
needed somebody else making calls I
needed somebody to collab you need to
think you need to start thinking how
could you make 10 times more contacts
into that cold Market rule number 15
give back some of you asking every day
like every day I get this question dude
why do you keep pushing so hard why
because I'm passionate about charity
I want to give back
I want to help
I wanted to help my mom when I was 16
and I couldn't I'm finally in a position
to help out the reason I have worked so
hard for 30 years was so I could have
money this is the way I looked at
everything hey hey Grant get your money
right
get your money right take that extra
money the reason I worked hard extra
hours you were working a 40-hour week
and I was working 100 hour a week the
reason I worked the extra 60 hours was
so I had extra money
all extra money all extra money went
into real estate y'all didn't know I was
doing this
nobody knew I was doing this I was
working for car dealers and Ashley
Furniture and big retailers and big
companies I would travel on Thanksgiving
to Canada to get a check for 30 000 for
speaking miss my family on Thanksgiving
Day leave my family on Thanksgiving Day
man I missed so many Thanksgiving every
Thanksgiving for 20 years I went to
Canada you know why because they don't
celebrate Thanksgiving and I could get
money on that day and everybody's like
you're missing Thanksgiving I missed the
Super Bowls I missed the World Series so
that I could get extra money and drop it
into this thing and this money would
then create passive income for me
passive income that I could then give to
charity
okay I have either given or raised 200
million dollars for charity you can't do
that without money it's impossible rule
number 16 try flipping if you don't have
any money you should be doing flips
but you only should do flips and
Wholesales until you have money to find
a flip Define a flip up I find a place
uh uh he wants to sell it I tell him I
gotta buyer for it I I've never done
this this is not my space but I know
guys that teach us successfully and then
I put a contract on that and then go out
to the marketplace and sell that and
pick up the spread between
uh uh what we contracted and what it's
worth what somebody else will pay for it
okay or flip could be hey I find a piece
of property I buy with a little bit of
money as mine hey I'm gonna live here I
put three or four percent down or
nothing fix it flip it that could be a
flip okay can you flip in on a
descending model is it only work in a
box of any time you can always flip it
only works in up markets you can always
probably flip but look when when the
football is over when it's all over it's
all over rule number 17 go big or go
bigger everybody needs to think bigger
go bigger Natalie she's over there would
you make a couple hundred grand last
year what a damn shame okay she needs to
start thinking about how would I go from
150 Grand a year she's probably so happy
with herself right now this is the most
money I've ever made in my life people
around are saying oh my God you're doing
so good Natalie this is great okay Kayla
goes back to Wisconsin oh my God you
work for that Maniac that barbaric Grant
Cardone that guy must be tough to work
for but she's getting paid good money
and they're all oh my God you're doing
so good Kayla Kayla needs to think about
how can she 10x how do you do that right
how do you go from being a personal
assistant making a hundred and whatever
a hundred thousand dollars a year let's
say I don't know what Kayla makes okay
it's below my pay grade I don't need to
know that how does she start thinking
about how do I turn this into a million
dollars regardless of whether she's 20
or her position or wherever how can she
multiply time how can she multiply money
how can she multiply opportunity go big
or
go bigger get rid of this go home option
okay I don't know who gave you guys this
option that's not an option I can't go
home I have to go bigger and by the way
I'm not interested in home I'm
interested in prosperity in Paradise I'd
like to never go home rule number 18
invest your money so I've got about
seven hundred thousand dollars just
sitting in the bank yeah and it's been
sitting there for about two years now
anyway we've got there just kind of has
a safety net we've got about
1.5 million in debt and then we bring in
about 500 000 a month and so my question
is should I should I keep that 700 000
from there as a safety net or should I
be looking somewhere to invest it or
should I just invest it right back into
the company okay well I mean like okay
number one the first thing I'd would
tell you to always do is keep investing
in your company I would not I would not
hold this money on reserve
okay money is to be used okay I got I
got I got a bunch of money sitting in my
pocket right now it is of no use to me
zero use to me sitting in my pocket it's
like is it a cushion I mean what's gonna
happen like the only way that money
helps me is if I follow my face and like
it cushions my my dick
but man but you see we're all brought up
save the money save the money save the
money save the money Reserve save for a
rainy day something bad's gonna happen
what I would do with this dude is some
portion of this but I would expect
because your business is doing well
you're already invested in your money in
your business right
yes so at some point if your business is
working bro what I want to do is I want
to get this money over here I would not
pay this debt off
this wouldn't even bother me by the way
okay do you
I don't even think about debt somebody
said the other day Cardone said he
doesn't like to use debt not you need to
you need to pay attention to what I'm
teaching you
I want to use good debt debt that I can
use to make me money is good debt
okay debt on a home isn't that good
okay so I don't know what your debt is
for but I know this yeah go ahead
the that's just uh operating cost you
know we've got a buildings trucks yeah
good good good dude so it's making you
money that's part of your business now
this is what I would do with this money
though okay I want this money how much
do you earn a year
uh me personally or at the business you
you personally
uh about 80. 80 000. so I'm gonna take
that 700 by the way I would take every
penny of it
and I want to put it in some I want to
put it into an investment
okay I want to put in an investment that
cannot be lost
so that excludes the entire Wall Street
okay okay I want to put in an investment
by the way there are investments that
cannot that will not be lost I can show
them to you okay and I want that to earn
me 70 grand 50 to 70 000 in year one
passive income I don't want you working
for that money rule number 19 be ready
for the long game what was the so the
fish was the first thing you sold well
yeah but but you know yeah I had a drug
problem you really sell the car what was
it like I sold automobiles when you
really like Snap in it's obviously a way
that you sell right is there a strategy
or no it's just hot it's like it's
mostly hard work you think or there's a
strategy of a lot of stuff you teach
it's strategy yeah that's right yes
there's there's no strategy that works
without somebody to talk to all right so
what's what's the ultimate what's this
you know the ultimate ultimate like like
I've been teaching strategy for 20 years
but again like if people would just
spend time on the funnel
on the traffic on the opportunity on the
marketing side equation it is the it is
the it is the the Holy Grail
like look around man look you know you
don't go to Amazon and have anybody sell
anything to you it's the funnel
it's it's the traffic
so I made that I made that mistake of
thinking I'm going to be great at what I
say to them I'm going to close the deal
right you know
um I got to keep my funnel close uh a
full I got to keep that final full so I
have something to close okay so how
about how about let's assume that you
have that so I figured out you're a
master of the funnel right yeah then you
don't know then then you won't even ask
this question you need to sell you won't
need you won't but you have a sales
force right yeah yeah and there are
things they need to say by the end of
the day if he's talking to 10 people a
day and another guy's talking under 200
people a day
the guy that talks to 200 is going to
win the game and if there's one skill
you want to learn is how to how to move
through 200 without it causing you it's
like the ball players you see these guys
play involved they don't get upset
because they lose the game
like it doesn't bother them they're in
it for the long run they're they're you
know and this is what the sales guy or
sales manager doesn't know you got to
get people ready for the long game rule
number 20 have fun every time we raise
money for Cardone capital or somebody
buys a seat for the 10x Road conference
we come out here
[Applause]
foreign
study success people should be studying
the most successful companies in the
world not not individuals don't worry
about Dave or Gary or Tony or Grant what
are successful people doing you know I
one of the biggest mistakes I've made in
my life was tracking
people that were doing better than me
so what like like like I made so many
dumbass decisions because uh Dave did it
or The Millionaire Next Door that that
book
I don't want to be The Millionaire Next
Door I want to know what Jeff Bezos is
doing I want to know what the boys at
Google are doing okay why why does a guy
like Mark Zuckerberg go from college
dorm room to one of the richest people
on the planet
that's who we should be studying and and
don't listen to everybody else
because those people have Financial
Freedom to the point to where they they
can do anything they want like you
cannot mess up some of these people's
situations
they couldn't screw it up if they wanted
to
so uh the 10x rule is is a it says hey
look you want to scale to a point
to where you have the life you deserve
it's not about the money you want or the
money you need scale your business so
you can walk away from it and money
never stops taking care of you and your
family you don't need to study 27
different warrants
you study one more and you're probably
going to be good most of us because of
Instagram and Facebook and YouTube we're
listening to so many different people
that that people do nothing
this this is a new crisis of our era
people are doing nothing not because
they're lazy because they have data that
is conflicting
so if you listen to Dave Dave says buy a
house then you listen to grant grant
says that's stupid you're not going to
do anything and if you're never going to
buy any real estate hey go ahead and buy
one house yeah you're going to regret it
later and you're gonna be like I wish
I'd have done what Cardone said but but
you got to do something and what you
don't want to do is listen to God and
the devil
because then you get stuck in purgatory
and you don't have any fun at all rule
number 22 help others look for somebody
to help man there's people all over this
planet man just lost I told my mom when
I was 16 years old one day one day I'm
going to be successful one day one day
I'm gonna be successful and one day I'm
gonna help a lot of people
and I said that to her because I wanted
somebody to help me see I've always
loved helping people
always I am most happy when I'm helping
someone else nothing to do with money if
I can help somebody
give them something but if I can
actually help somebody to feel better
about themselves
and know what to do in a phone call to
know what to do on a sales call to know
how to follow up their girlfriend or
their boyfriend or to solve some problem
in their life or how to get some money
why don't we do this man
keep it thank you boss
that's what I did that just like pop
help somebody rule number 23 use
negativity as fuel
looks like I'm showing off all the time
here's what you don't know
you don't see all the hard work the
years the years
don't quit okay if I to quit
I wouldn't have the wife wouldn't have
the kids wouldn't have the bird wouldn't
have the cars wouldn't have the real
estate wouldn't have my middle my
physical and my mental health I wouldn't
have the success nobody would know me
nobody would know me
so you see where I'm at today but you
don't see all the days that I got up
when I didn't want to get up all the
days when I went to work and made a call
when I didn't want to make a call all
the days that I called somebody back
that had rejected me over and over and
over again all the book publishers that
wouldn't publish my books all the TV
people that said no man you're too noisy
all that all the things that are
happening to you right now the sick days
the illnesses the family that's pulling
against you the friends that counted you
out uh the problems you've had in your
past whatever it is look you can use it
as an excuse or you can use it as fuel
rule number 24 be hard on yourself I
just had a coaching call with some
friends of mine they come in every month
and and they're working on their
business they're going to bust a million
dollars this month when I met them they
were literally the company was not
making money they're going to make a
million dollars they asked me a question
today that I want to talk about they're
like dude how are you
everybody we talked to talks about being
nice to their people taking care of
their people doing this for their people
why is it the the the answer you have is
different I said what do you mean well
it seems like you're hard on people
[Music]
I said no man I'm not being hard on
people
I'm just trying to take care of my
environment
I'm not trying I don't practice being a
a dik
I'm trying to take care of my
environment my decisions are about my
environment right so little Grant a
little grants this this little phone
right here this is little Grand he got
issues he needs to clean up his issues
Grant's got to get hard on Grant
okay you you guys out there y'all y'all
so soft on your people it's because
you're soft on yourself
right that's why you end up with no
money you end up with people betraying
you you end up with people taking
advantage of you even your kids don't
appreciate you do you got to be hard on
yourself I'm hard on everybody around me
but mostly I'm hard on me rule number 25
become the person you should be a theme
that runs in my life is just
disappointment throughout the whole
thing particularly the first from fifth
from 10 years old to 25.
and then 25 to 50 you know yeah I was
doing better because I I had a drug
problem in 16. oh you did yeah was that
the disappointment or was it like no no
no no the drugs were just the drugs were
a byproduct you know it was the
disappointment was
uh you know
the school thing school was
disappointing no uncles no dad right no
I didn't know Direction Just boredom
that's why what you do with these rate
the races at least keep somebody
occupied for some moment of time that
gives them a goal big enough and a
challenge sure I didn't have any
challenges you didn't have anybody like
setting some goals up in front of you no
no when my dad died I kept waiting for
one of the uncles to step up and they
didn't got it and that pissed me off
because I'm like dude somebody's got to
step up and give me a little guidance
here but you but you had older um
Brothers my older brother died when I
was 20 right so 10 years after my dad
died so there was no men
got a just a bunch of women and my mom
wasn't like setting big goals for you no
no my mom my mom my mom grew up in bread
lines so right you know I'd go to my mom
I remember I did a deal when I was 30.
bought my first piece of Real Estate
and um Mom I bought this piece of real
estate it was three million dollars a
1.9 million dollars and she's like well
that's great but you know I just I love
you just the way you are right and I
hung up the phone she said that to me a
thousand times
and I hope the phone said yeah but I
don't love me the way I am and then the
my counselor buddy Dale says You Need To
Love Yourself the way you are I said
ain't never gonna happen
right I said that's the big lot I don't
want to love me the way I don't want to
become the guy I should be rule number
26 stack up some experience nobody ever
told me when I was going to school
seniors of school nobody ever said hey
maybe you want to Stack up some
experiences
and then what happens is kids rather
than going to college what they do today
is they'll go travel for for a year
dude what you ought to flip it go get
your work ethic again
Bank some money Bank some money I'm
gonna do this left-handed Bank some
money and then go on the trip of your
life
oh left-handed I'm so good I'm so good
at everything
you gotta have confidence man so look
look and by the confidence comes from
doing stuff
not for traveling right like I know
people that traveled when they were
young and then they go back into the
workplace in their business place and
they're like dude I don't have any
confidence in business
you want to have confidence in business
confidence and money confidence with
your family confidence that you can go
places and look money might not make you
happy I know some of you believe that
but
it gives you the security to go where
you want do what you want and stay as
long as you want if you can get that
money right Rule Number 27 be fair to
yourself yesterday I had to make a phone
call to a guy hey bro you're not getting
the deal let me tell you what the deal
is it's 115 million dollar loan
okay and there's two groups doing the
deal
they're going to hate seeing this when
they see it one group is at .40 one
group is point twenty five zero this is
my friend right here my friends too much
money man and this guy this other guy
over here got me more proceeds he gave
me more assurances I had to tell my
friends sorry bro
sorry I gotta go with my boy down here
oh man Grant we've been friends we've
been friends you like me I like you
we've been to dinner you know my family
sorry bro
I don't know what to tell you dude it
would not be fair to my family to my
children to my investments to my money
to my hard work to this deal to my
investors it would not be fair by the
way if there were no investors it would
not be fair to me
to pay more money to do business with
you because you're my friend sorry I
don't know what to tell you
this is where you guys all get confused
he's my friend if he's my friend then I
should not have to pay for that
relationship
by the way if he's my friend he will be
my friend after I make this hard
decision rule number 28 have a dream and
I remember hearing a story my twin
brother told me years ago about this
dude I think his name was Vincent
wealthy wealthy dude in London
everywhere he went
he went on a Choppa what a way to ride
on okay I knew I was not in a place that
ever knew that but I always thought
every once in a while I'd be like dude
what would it take you know what I did I
quit on the dream before I even had the
dream I'm like I'll never have that been
on the dream before I had the dream
I've done this my whole life don't make
this mistake look at me
huh it's really comfortable okay
don't quit on the dream before you have
the dream okay and and when I heard that
Vincent was flying around on a
helicopter all the time I quit on my
dream before I even had it I just
assumed I could never do that I'll never
have that and then one day I went back
and started looking at dude what do I
have to do to go back and make my dreams
a reality and even if they don't become
a reality at least half the dream rule
number 29 be prepared I was in a deal I
was in a deal and I sold the deal I made
four million dollars on the deal I
already knew and I made the mistake of
judging based on the profit rather than
the opportunity okay the guy that bought
the deal from me ended up selling it for
um 13 million more so you would have
made 17 I'd have made 17 million rather
than 4 million okay so now why do I tell
you that because it I did not know when
I was a young salesman at 25 26 27 years
so any more than Jared yeah when he
started working here or when he had a
job at that that corporate company when
they cut your bonus yeah they jacked you
um he did not know then and he would be
negotiating 100 million dollar contracts
at a company I did not know when I was
selling automobiles in 25 26 years old
that I Was preparing
for 100 million dollar deals when I
would be 55 years old yeah like you you
guys don't like you got to be more
positive about where your show ends up
right you got to train today like I'm
going to be in a big deal tomorrow
right because it's going to happen if
you just stay focused on it so for those
of you Jared made a good point about the
sales thing you don't think you're a
salesperson because you're you're
running a dental business yeah your top
line is your Revenue line that's called
sales dude have you got a problem Gus if
you if you get a lot so much distraction
right okay so let me know all right if
you if you buy a car and you pay too
much like like you could every time
everybody could deal poorly and you
could pay too much money and interest
you could pay too much money for the car
that could cost you five to ten Grand
you could buy a house and negotiate a
bad loan you could buy at the wrong time
you could negotiate a bad deal that
could cost dude in 2008 people lost
hundreds of thousands of dollars and
people made millions and hundreds of
millions watching the opportunity so it
you can't see opportunities you're not
ready for okay you cannot catch a wave
you're not prepared to Surf it is
impossible rule number 30 have fun look
at this dude I thought it was chilly
no it felt so good
that breeze is nice
come on boys
you know the story of the
the young bull
and the elbow at the top of the top of
the hill right no one got that joke
earlier yeah well you know the story
right the young boy says to the whole
bowl of sister there you go oh man one
week old bull why don't we go down there
breathable breed one of that cattle
breed something in cows
and an old bull says hey why don't we
just go down there and breed them all
has a 10x bull right there rule number
31 be the best known Facebook Instagram
Twitter Snapchat
uh LinkedIn
I probably posted about this event more
than the entire room combined
today
in addition to all the other stuff I'm
doing how many old people here let me
see a hand if you consider yourself an
old person
okay thank you thanks sir appreciate it
you're like dude it's just kind of like
I didn't do it I'm 61 years old man
[Music]
I'm 61 years old and and I'm banging on
these mechanisms because they're gifts
they're gifts their gifts from the gods
if you have a great service and a great
great product and you have a great
company raise your hand if you have
those three things
to tell the world okay because the the
cycle the business cycle your business
survivability okay your business success
is dependent upon first marketing well I
can't do it I don't have the money it's
because your goals are wrong
you're not going to pay for the
marketing and advertising who's going to
pay for it
the guy that paid for the fifteen
thousand dollar package
the ROI what is the wrong nothing
[Music]
okay
what's your return on investment
every I grew up in the ROI school okay I
have 14 businesses today started four of
them in the last 60 days
okay I I want expansion what is the ROI
this is the business consultant I need
to see the ROI I don't I don't do rois
on any of my businesses
I make a decision is it a good business
decision do people need to know who I am
okay I have never studied the return on
an ad that I did on YouTube or Facebook
or Instagram or CNBC I don't need a
return I need people to know me
okay you guys need to switch this thing
you need to switch it how many have cash
in the bank let me see hands if you have
cash to make good good then you're not
committed to your business to the degree
that you have cash in the bank
how many of you have equity in your
homes let me see a hand if you have
equity in your house raise your damn
hands y'all proud of it okay if to the
degree that you have equity in your
house you are not committed to your
business and you will never take big
Pharma down
do you need that money to fight the war
I don't I don't have equity in a house
okay I have equity in my business
okay I get cash
put it in my business
I get more cash I put it in more
business right I put it in people
knowing me because if they don't know me
who's gonna win the war whoever's best
known wins best product never wins you
want to write this down best product
never wins never has one never will win
best known always wins rule number 32
leave the nest look if you don't have
your thing whatever it is the job the
money the girl your goals your dreams
you gotta leave Where You Are
you can't win a mission from home
we don't win Wars at home
you understand you got to go someplace
the world's changing how many agree the
world's changing right now did the world
is changing it's changing so fast right
you got it you got to take the old ideas
that you have and you got to look at
them again today and say hey is this
true anymore
is it true what am I doing what are me
and the wife doing what business are we
building do I need to work for myself do
I really or do I need to find the right
vehicle that can go far enough long
enough provide enough revenue for the
right people and get to the top of the
food chain rule number 33 set ethical
targets you've probably heard me say set
a Target and never drop that Target ever
we don't drop targets here okay I'm not
a communist
I'm not the enemy and I ain't the devil
I got enough people pulling against me I
set a Target okay if I set a Target if
I'm honest I don't lie to myself either
by the way like a lot of you sales
people out there you sales people that
lie to yourselves you sales people that
are dishonest you sales people that are
unethical you know what I'm talking
about I'm talking about most of you
you set a Target below your potential
you're unethical right you have this
potential and you set your target here
or somebody else set your target
you're a damn liar lying to your mama
your wife your husband your kids lying
to yourself rule number 34 use equity to
produce cash flow today I have about 300
million dollars worth of equity
earning
about six percent a year
on average
18 million dollars a year
before I go to work
and I still work
so houses don't do that cars don't do
that businesses do that rental
properties do that you take Equity out
of a house or a car you put it into a
business that produces cash flow and you
create personal financial freedom for
yourself your household your family your
friends and your investors
okay this doesn't stop you can't stop
this the economy tanks it still keeps
coming in
this is how Financial wealth has been
created for hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of years it's not going to stop
these These are tried and true methods
get the equity out of your car in your
house and get it into something that
produces cash flow rule number 35 make
success your drug everybody's going to
lose something dude I've lost dogs I
lost my older brother you you're not if
if the reason you're going to become a
drug addict is because you lost your
daddy man everybody should be a drug
addict everybody that never connected
I'm like oh you were abandoned by your
father or he abandoned you I'm like he
died heart blew up in his chest yeah
okay so I'm like what what is the
problem here the reason I got on drugs
broke was because I was bored you're
bored I would have taken anything
you could have offered me homosexuality
yeah let's roll I'm in uh you could have
offered me uh uh a marathon
yeah I'll do I'll run a marathon you
could have offered me anything that
would have been interesting
right I would have I would have taken it
I was looking for leadership man I was
looking for activity I was looking for
aggression yeah what can I do you know
it's interesting McGregor he talks about
he's like look I don't win because of my
skills I win because I'm obsessed
and and so I took out of that Treatment
Center
um
they introduced me to Other Drugs by the
way they wanted me to take these other
uh Adderall or phenobarbital or
something did you take those or no I
brought them home with me and threw them
away and said you know what my new drug
is going to become
success rule number 36 use debt to grow
remember this 64 of businesses in
America Break Even or lose money okay
check this out 22 out of 28 million
small businesses in America have no
employees zero employees what kind of
business is that man
I am the master and the slave
The Prisoner the warden the jailhouse
the system
that you're stuck on a business you
cannot do the soul preneur thing even
though you see some guy on Instagram
rolling out with a Lambo
okay it's [ __ ] that's not a business
a business is people in a company
anybody know any major successful person
that that didn't have a bunch of
employees anybody here know any great
company that had one employee
one flow of income
that didn't use debt
okay caterpillar debt Coca-Cola debt
Ford Motor Company debt they had to use
debt you got to use debt to expand you
can't stay small and expect the world to
know you it's impossible how many of
your parents told you this don't get too
much attention fly under the radar don't
toot your own horn be seen and not
heard dude you don't get attention today
you have absolutely zero chance of being
successful
Money Follows attention rule number 37
focus on cash flow let me tell you the
thing that I'm most proud of this month
every month these are checks okay about
300 checks I think I got a bunch more
coming here that I just finished signing
these go out every month what John
okay this is not payroll
we got 100 people here to get payroll
this this is not payroll checks these
are people that I pay every month
because they invested money with me and
my real estate
cash flow baby cash is not King cash
flow is King and it's the strong people
that make the hard decisions that end up
with the cash flow
you softies end up spending all your
money the softies have the cash flow
bleed out of the organization and it
goes back into the marketplace my cash
flow ends up in the hands of my friends
my family my momsies my dadsies my
uncles my aunts my cuz my friends my
buds my johns Jared the people that like
hey Grant I like what you're doing dude
rule number 38 be aggressive so let's
just start with the aggression thing
okay so like when I tell you guys like
hey you know like I am aggressive and
aggressive works for me the reality is
everyone's aggressive yeah like from the
very first moment like if you watch
sperms sperm cell is it a cell I think
it's Burns to sell right so when it's
finding an egg you're talking about
massive aggression yeah you're talking
about obsessive
uh
uh tremendous like if if that was the
original beginning of the individual
which I don't think it is we're talking
about
a trajectory
more violent
uh with more purpose more driven that
means all of us have that
you know and and like if you ever just
go go
well you know the the activity of a
sperm right it is it's pretty violent
yeah right now it's a crazy stat because
like you're like like the chance of you
being born are like one in a billion or
something like that yeah there's a lot
of them a lot of them competing for that
for that connection right so
um and then even when you make it you
might not make it so
when people say man you're too
aggressive you're not aggressive enough
right
the only people that have problem with
aggressive again I would talk about Mike
Tyson just because it's so fresh in my
mind I said yeah he's like man man but
granted you know the aggression thing
and the ego and the accomplishments and
he's like it's too much and I'm like no
dude it was fine yeah Mike when you were
winning you were doing better in all
areas of life the only people you didn't
have a problem Mike the people around
you had a problem with it yeah they were
trying to filter you down yeah and I
said you know I said when you
I'll bet that other areas of your life
were actually affected because of your
winning not when you were losing when
you were winning he's like you know
actually his grades he was terrible
student he says when I won my first
fight my grades got better see that's
right bro because you're winning and
winning is important Even in our society
today we say don't be aggressive don't
be noisy don't promote yourself too much
don't win too much don't succeed too
much don't get too much money you know
and
this is probably why school didn't gel
with you dude because you you have this
you you were able to keep awake this
this mission that you're going to be
somebody special because you know you
should be rule number 39 don't aim to
break even find a job you love how many
how many heard that before you got to
find a job you love man
okay how many heard that before you got
to find something you love the only way
to be successful is find something you
need to find a job that's gonna make you
some money
okay it's money man you
economic Planet this isn't a planet
about Army Navy this isn't a bland about
white or black short or tall male or
female this is an economic Planet if you
got enough money nobody cares what you
look like how you talk or what your
language is
this is what they didn't teach you in
school this is the only reason I went to
school I wanted money
64 of all businesses in America Break
Even or lose money
listen to what I'm telling you right now
64 of every business in America there's
28 million of them
Break Even or lose money and it doesn't
matter if the economy is good or bad
they break even or lose money here's the
freaking phenomenal thing okay Break
Even shouldn't be a category
who would make break even a category
break in even is losing
if I told you that you're gonna put a
bunch of resources a bunch of time
you're going to work your ass off every
day you're not going to see your wife
and your kids most of the time you're
going to be terrified every second of
every day
to break even
what would you say rule number 40 have
fun I got all my friends on the walls
here I've got lady eveline don't trip
lady Evelyn y'all know about lady Evelyn
huh
okay so we got we got my boy what's my
boy's name right here
that was Alfred
this outfit yeah
this dude Bad to the Bone okay now
Evelyn tricked him into marrying him
okay because she was a conniving
none of this is true just like Elena
is sitting right in front of her
boy right in between them and then we
got then we got my boy Isaac Newton now
this is Isaac Newton
um
the role of Portsmouth not Isaac Newton
the Apple guy by the way April no there
is Isaac Newtons yeah whatever this is
dark blue Dorothy was a cross-dresser
okay I just said yeah
um Sir Anthony Sir Anthony was a banker
and he financed all this stuff
this dude right here uh The Honorable
Newton Walla this is the man right here
okay he's the man who put all this
together and then we got his sister over
here the original name of the family was
a fellow's daughter of Thomas Coulson
that married into the wallet because you
know the Wallop you know where they got
their name the Wallops no they gave some
they walloped
yeah so and this uh this lady right here
she just they they had extra space in
the wall so they threw her up there rule
number 41 commit to getting known four
things I want to give you number one on
building a brand all right
first of all number number one because
some of you have a problem right here
you don't even like you don't even want
this
first thing you got to do is commit to
getting known
you have to get rid of this idea that
your mommy and daddy gave you fly under
the radar don't get known some of you
just don't want to get known you're
you're literally hiding
well
uh I'm gonna I'm gonna open it up an
Instagram account and I'm gonna put it
on private
dude if you're going to have a private
Instagram account don't have an
Instagram account if I see your accounts
private I will not follow you
why would I follow you rule number 42
don't waste money I know guys in solar
they go out and make 70 grand in a month
yeah
and one you go on vacation yeah that's
just a violation of what made you the 70
grand it's so stupid yeah it's Insanity
yeah oh I deserve it I work so hard dude
you're lucky
and double down
all in all like you're you're lucky yeah
okay uh Lebron makes a three-pointer he
doesn't go do a layup but he may he goes
in like he's like dude I got these three
pointers down like what do you do after
you make a three-pointer you throw
another one from the same spot yeah
because the basket gets bigger you don't
take off now I knew you freaking lean
into it right when I was 25 dude I was
so scared if I sold somebody something
I'm like oh my God this is only going to
last for another minute or two go meet
somebody go talk to somebody I'd sell a
second person I'm like oh I'm on fire
now like I can sell anybody people walk
up I'd sold five or six cars in one day
I'm like I thought I was a damn like
I've been like
Stan Lee had somehow you know influenced
me into some super freaking character
and I was like I walked up to a lady one
night it was I must have been 10 30 11
o'clock at night I had sold six cars
that day I was like I was in this the
Zone yeah and I walked out and I said
how about no money down and nothing a
month
and she's like huh no money down no
money a month you never have to pay for
it she's like for how long
I'm like man I got it you got it okay
next thing you know she's buying
something from you yeah because I was in
the zone so what I would tell people out
there is like look when you make money
you need a plan with money number one
get it you don't have to make it earn it
yeah two keep it don't buy [ __ ] with it
yeah okay don't buy don't spend money on
stuff until you have cash flow that can
buy stuff like the when you guys see me
out spending money there I bought in
December I bought two rolls royce I
bought a cullinan 449
000 car yeah and I bought my wife a
wraith it's 425 000 okay
at least one of them sand the lease on
one of them for 24 months and and wrote
a check for cash for the other one okay
yeah so
earn more money that month from free
cash flow I'm not I'm not working for it
my real estate paid me enough money to
pay for both of those cars right there
right there now I didn't pay for the
cars my cash flow did so earn it keep it
don't buy watches don't buy fancy
don't buy Lambos don't rent Lambos don't
go on fancy vacations don't buy your
little trinkets until your cash flow can
pay for it not your time rule number 43
put yourself in an uncomfortable
environment I was with the shake the the
minister of Tolerance there I was
sitting next to him he had me at a
meeting I'm sitting to his right in this
big beautiful round room
and there's all mostly men in the room
three women and this this meeting they
people come in and just meet him every
afternoon wow three o'clock in the
afternoon hello how you doing they pay
respects
um he's got me on his right he's got the
minister
the prime minister of uh Thailand on his
left
Mr 10x and Mr Thailand
and he reaches over touches me on the
knee and he's like
would you like to fly to Dubai we were
in Abu Dhabi he's like would you like to
fly to Dubai with me on my helicopter
I said yes sir I would now I don't know
if that includes Elena or not so I'm
hitting these fixed ideas I'm like I
wonder if that means my wife is invited
so so the point of this story is like no
matter where you're at in life if you're
still learning and you're still in
putting yourself in uncomfortable or new
environments you're going to be a little
I don't know what the cultures are
you know when I was with the policeman
and they were investigating me and Dubai
I crossed my legs like this the guy
walked in and says please please
sit proper I'm like yeah okay man what's
the deal here I ran into it like that
that there in in the Middle East dude to
see the bottom of a soul is so
disrespectful really but this is also
disrespectful this is considered to be
aggressive my leg was shaking when you
started
this is like because I'm not showing I
knew about the soul thing don't show the
soul but this is considered aggressive
by the police gotcha and and so I'm like
yeah man but but you see all these
things are like I think I think people
think oh my God Grant's got it made you
know he's successful now everywhere he
goes he's he can talk to 35 000 people
I'm still uncomfortable in situations I
still have fixed limited beliefs in in
in things that trap me right so you know
we're doing we're doing and do you
prefer to put yourself in those
situations yeah I have to I have to
agree
I have to agree to put myself in those
so that I feel like I'm I'm expanding
like like I'm living life like you can't
be a beast
or a Savage
if you're not in the jungle
you know you can't I know guys that
think they're beast and they're on their
self but bro you and yourself you're
watching you're watching beast on TV
you're not a beast so you got it to be a
be to be a true Savage like a real
living
uh in a respectful honorable way I say
that and I say that like like I respect
people that are savages and and um to
get things done that they're like hey
man give me the ball again right uh
was it Tim Grover would say well but the
cleaner the cleaner yeah yeah you got to
be in the game to be a cleaner you can't
you can't be on a couch you can't be
behind a book
you got to be in environments that are
not comfortable not oh you're on stage
for the 67th time doing the same
presentation that's not a cleaner that's
a guy on on auto you're just doing the
same thing you did over and over again
rule number 44 practice being hard no
one thing no one thing will blow a good
relationship there's not one thing I can
tell my wife my wife says hey you're
getting fat
okay what is that How's that gonna hurt
me
y'all got to get hard man y'all got to
practice being hard y'all got to
practice telling people the truth y'all
got to practice being hard on yourselves
you got to practice maybe not
taking every weekend off
okay I had a bunch of people leave my
office the other night at six o'clock
Dave Robards is walking out of here all
these guys walking out at 603 Natasha's
leaving at 6 to 30. I'm like oh yo you
guys are all rich now huh why do you
think you gotta leave why do you guys
think you've earned a right to leave at
six o'clock
right why do you guys think you've
earned the right to charge overtime for
everything that you do over time
oh I need to get my overtime no you
don't you need to add values what you
need to do you need to get hard on
yourself rule number 45 build the muscle
of Courage if you took everything away
from me right now the the things that
are most valuable to me you can't take
away so you take the plane away you take
the money away take the real estate Port
the portfolio away
three years from now I'll be bigger than
I was because now I have courage like if
you guys can just find your courage man
and that that's a muscle you got to go
build a muscle of Courage I have courage
nobody can take that away from you can't
steal it from me you can't beat it out
of me rule number 46 learn how to cold
call before you diversify go go bang on
another door yeah you need to become the
freaking door banging number of the
universe so I want to talk about that
right can I use that word here 100 you
need to become like you need to go yeah
you need to go bang on the door they
tell you to get out of the neighborhood
and you go figure out how to bang on it
again and not get arrested yeah like if
you can figure that gig out I guarantee
you you will be the most successful
person your genetic code has ever
generated yeah anyone in your family
everybody I know says man learn how to
cold call I I have the career I have
today because I'm because I learned how
to code so rule number 47 respect money
I respect a hundred dollars
so if you give me a hundred dollars you
know I respect that as a lot of money
gotcha now that being said it's not
going to be a lot for very long and if
you've got two kids that need to eat
today depends on what your needs are
right I got a wife and two kids so I
mean 100 is probably going to last the
whole day
uh but a hundred dollars for a minute
that's a lot of money now if I could if
I could figure out how to get more money
coming in it's only a lot of money if
you got more money coming in I
understand because I can all I can
probably exhaust almost any amount of
money this is this is the problem with
the the NFL the MBA uh the MLB the the
the the rappers when they move on they
got a pile of money but what they don't
have is more money coming in gotcha and
and so now you know a million dollars is
a lot of money if you got
a thousand dollars every day coming in
because you can't get to it I always
tell Elaine I said dude as long as we
make a dollar more
because of my net worth if I make a
dollar just one dollar every day
I mean one dollar today is a lot of
money because it means I never go
backwards rule number 48 believe I have
belief now I know I know what I can do
now once you know what you can do then
you can do it a second time and and
that's why so many people can go
bankrupt and then come come right back
because they know now
the first time you do it you don't know
the second time you do it you're like I
think maybe the third and fourth time
you're like I know for sure I could do
this rule number 49 be great at one
thing there was a time when nobody knew
my name
all right nobody knew my name
I didn't I hadn't written a book I
didn't have 21 best-selling programs
uh I wasn't doing audiences my first gig
my first gig I talked to seven people
for eight hours
how long like how long did that go on
for three years oh how long did people
not know me yeah oh nobody knew me
really until the last three years so I
want you guys to hear that how many I've
been doing this how many years of doing
that 20 I've been doing this I've been
doing the pitch thing since 30.
I'm 61. 31 31 years nobody's known me
until the last two or three years maybe
and would you and then Mike Tyson man
where you been man why doesn't everybody
know you man yeah why doesn't everybody
know you Steve Harvey dude everybody
should know who you are you should have
a TV show that was my fault man I was
thinking too small I was running down a
little Channel yeah but too many of you
guys you're trying to run down too many
channels in the beginning
or or trying to cross all you got to get
good at one thing first yeah you can't
you're not going to be great at two
things if you're not great at one thing
it's impossible yeah you can't serve two
ways at the same time and get good at
one wave get get good at a left
okay and and so you've got to get good
at one thing it doesn't matter if you
like it either you don't need to like it
to get great at it yeah like everybody's
like oh I gotta follow my passion
particularly here in La yeah I'm an
artist
okay oh
I meant to do this dude you're meant to
do a lot of stuff yeah okay ask Steven
Spielberg he was not meant to do one
thing he's meant to do a lot of things
we all are
and so it's not it's not some freak
phenomenon that a guy can write
uh fiction and non-fiction and do movies
okay and
um you know also be a massive investor
in companies yeah it's not true
it's it's something about guy oh how can
a guy write you know this and that and
do all this and put together these
volumes and help people and start to you
know because because he can and you can
too yeah everybody can but you got to
get good at one thing you got to groove
into one thing make sure you're certain
about one thing before you move on to
the second thing because you're just
going to be like I'm still in doubt
about the first thing but I'm gonna try
to get great at this thing and you know
you didn't finish this thing and rule
number 50 the last homie for a very
special bonus clip is think big I need
to think like the Google boys or the
Warren Buffett's or the guys that are
like they don't worry about all that
they're worried about how big they can
get how big how big can they get how
long can they survive and and big big is
what works you can't show me a small
company or a small thing that has ever
survived anything is this the your your
quote that says can't can't get big
thinking small you can't get big
thinking small you can't get big
with small people
I think a lot of people are trying to
create a brand
you're putting a logo together oh I like
it or you survey it with 10 people but
it doesn't matter people love it like
you could take a bad logo repeat it over
and over to the marketplace until it's
seared into the mind of the consumer so
number one I think
uh it's got to be quantity quantity of
of re-messaging over and over uh number
two it's the the audience it needs to be
easy for the audience to relate
whether they like it or hate it doesn't
really matter what matters is that it
gets it grabs their attention and the
third thing uh I would say is
um
and look I'm still trying to figure this
out I I don't know what our brand is I
think Brands you got to be open number
three to to it having it being a living
organism you are and it grows and
changes because you made it this far in
a video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome if you want to see the
one-on-one I did recently with Grant
check it out right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there true wealth
cannot be created working it can only be
created in best Elon muscles completely
invest
he has no cash and no houses